hey while you're here don't forget to
check out our brand new online store we
have original designs like this chick
magnet deku got a smashing mall shirt
created by pro artist Cuusoo midi you
can't find these designs anywhere else
so check us out at anime uproar comm
link in the description fans of the
channel can now use a special discount
code uproar 25 at checkout to receive an
instant 25% off
[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today I am adding one more
vid to the MHA fact series a series has
gotten a lot of love so thank you guys
for that today we are going to be doing
another video that was suggested by a
lot of you meana ashido guys if you like
this series make sure to Texas smash
that like button to let me know and
subscribe and ring that magic YouTube
belt so your serous sense goes off as
soon as a new MHA vid drops feel free to
suggest the next MHA video in the
comments if you got a video you're
burning up to see also we've pre-ordered
the my hero academia ones just this game
so we'll be playing it as soon as we get
it over on our anime uproar twitch
channel which I'll link in the
description so make sure to follow us
there now without further ado let's jump
into those acidic facts fact number one
before she settled on pinky mina a
shadow at first wanted her hero name to
be ridley hero alien queen this line is
a reference to the ridley scott's 1979
science fiction horror film alien mina
squirt was likely inspired by the aliens
from the movie franchise who also have
acidic bodily fluids that can melt
through skin and other materials and
this was Hanako she's way of paying
homage
however the hardcore alien fans may
notice an inconsistency here horikoshi
points out this inconsistency in some
extra manga materials which he calls a
shadows extremely adorable breakdown
corner
he writes since the alien queen appeared
in the sequel to alien technically I
should have gone with Cameron hero
instead of ridley hero since James
Cameron directed the sequel aliens but
the one whom everyone associates with
alien is director Ridley Scott sorry
about that
I personally watched a second film just
for this video cuz I haven't watched it
before and let's just say I definitely
prefer horikoshi is extremely adorable
alien queen - the nightmare inducing
aliens in the film's fact number 2 like
most of the other students in class 1a
Mina has changed since arica she came up
with her initial
sign her horns used to be bigger and had
a more complicated design the curved
horns however were considered too
complicated to draw every time Sol
horikoshi opted for the simpler horns
that we know so well what eco she also
decided to make her final design less
lanky and more thick her hair ended up
being shorter the visible or chuckle
style blushes were scrapped and her
smile is often less Sara like then it
appears in the initial design lastly in
the initial design Mina looks less sure
of herself let me know in the comments
if you prefer the final design more than
hard quarters initial one personally I
do since the final design seems to
complement her confident outgoing
personality much better fact number
three in the manga hood eco she
occasionally gives us character profiles
which break down a specific character
and gives us some extra often humorous
information about that you a file number
7 is all about Mina and horikoshi reveal
some fun details about her like that her
hair is like Dec ooze except her horns
get in the way while she is washing it
she also comments that her thighs are
healthy and that hace dos eyes give an
entirely different impression before
they're colored black I was curious
so of course I googled Mina ah she doe
with white eyes and I can say that she
looks like a completely different person
the black eyes definitely make her look
unique and so does her purplish pink
skin which as horikoshi reveals is that
way Duty effects of her quirk politico
she goes on to break down her acid quirk
in a clearer way
explaining that she can secrete a
corrosive liquid from her body and
control how corrosive or sticky it is
the liquid is versatile she can use it
to attack build defensive walls and use
it to quickly slide across the floor
this is why her hero costume boots are
custom made so that she can secrete acid
from her feet without melting the boots
although it appears that the acid cannot
hurt her hood eco she points out that
one wrong move and her fickle quirk
could melt the clothes right off her
body
I hear Minetta is still patiently
waiting for that day to come fact number
4
speaking of Moneta let's talk about the
fanservice even more so than momoyo
euros ooh Mina seems completely
comfortable with being naked which is
probably why hardcore she uses her so
much for fanservice you cannot deny that
there's a good deal of fanservice in the
anime and the same is the case with the
manga and other extra materials outside
of the main story horikoshi probably a
minute does request has created multiple
fanservice drawings of Mina for instance
in volume 9 of the manga what of course
she drew an image of Mina wearing
nothing but her underwear and boots
he wrote beside it I brought out of
ideas for stuff to put here so I'm going
to make it a workbook for practicing
sexy shots interestingly enough I had
the official English translation of
volume 9 and it appears that this
drawing did not make it into the
official English version horikoshi
releases Mina fanservice sketches on his
official Twitter as well along with
other MHA sketches so horikoshi clearly
likes fanservice and so does a lot of
his audience let me know how you feel
about fanservice in MHA and which girl
do you think is use the most for
fanservice is amina
momo or someone else fact number 5 now
let's talk about popularity we've
covered a lot of popular characters so
far in this series like Paco or choco
and deku but Mina believe it or not is
one of the less popular characters in
class 1a in the first three Japanese
popularity polls Mina could not break
into the top 20 the author horikoshi who
is not even a character in MHA made it
into the top 20 as did the Invisible
Girl the purple man and the hand villain
of the show and yet Mina could not make
it you'd think that people were voting
for Cameron's alien queen and not wholly
cautious
however Mina did get some love in the
West in the first u.s. popularity poll
Mina tied with me Hatsune for 9th place
and in the 2018 crunchyroll popularity
poll Mina got 10th place right ahead of
mobile interestingly enough even though
she gets little to no love in Japan she
does seem to consistently beat out Momo
in
West let me know what you think about
Mina would you put her in your top ten
fact number six now let's turn to Mina's
official statistics according to the my
hero academia data book Mina scored a
three out of five in power a four out of
five and speed a very impressive five
out of five in technique a 4 out of 5 in
cooperativeness and her worst score a 1
out of 5 in intelligence
so overall her stats are solid but her
intelligence level is one of the lowest
in the class the only person who scored
lower than her in class one A's grades
was Deng key who plays xx or in other
words last place these two are often
grouped together because of their lack
of academic prowess and some people even
ship them together let me know if you
ship Mina with kaminari or as I
mentioned in the Kitty Shima facts video
do you agree with me and Detroit shiver
with a zero hash tag horn buddies for
the win back number seven
despite her lackluster performance on
written exams though Mina is still one
of class one aides most promising
students for instance she ranked in the
top eight of the you a sports festival
which is no small feat additionally
horikoshi has said in the manga that she
ranks high up there even taking the
whole class into account but horikoshi
has not gotten around to properly
showing us her strong points yet however
there is hope for all the Mina fans out
there
horikoshi says that among the girls
she's the one he's most anxious to get
moving so we can definitely expect to
see her shine in the future fact number
8 in the original japanese mina is
voiced by the 31 year old Eddie ki
Tamura Eddie also voiced the blue haired
mean girl intruder and the pink haired
rich girl in high school of the dead
these anime are very different but I can
say I enjoyed them both thoroughly check
out high school did that if you like
zombies and fanservice and check out
another period if you haven't already if
that wasn't enough area is also an
amateur manga artist in her spare time
fact number 9 in the English dub Mina is
voiced by the 36
old caitlin Tiffany glass while still a
college student she went on a studio
tour of Funimation and was hired the
same day you may know her best as the
voice of winry rockbell in both Full
Metal Alchemist and Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood she also directed the
English version of Ouran High School
Host Club and voiced the main character
Haruhi and I'll mention that she was
yakumo in school Rumble because that is
just one of the funniest anime ever fact
number 10 now if you saw the other MHA
facts videos you know that I like doing
a lightning round of facts in place of
just one single tenth fact more facts
more fun so I will squeeze in as many
quick bonus facts as I can for you
understood okay three two one less Jam
Mina is 159 centimetres or five foot
three inches tall that makes her the
second tallest girl in the class after
Momo and places her right between the
darkbird fumika gay and her hair buddy
Deku Mina's blood type is a B and her
birthday is on July 30th according to
her manga but the official data book
actually put July 15th so there's a rare
inconsistency right there Mina loves
dancing and her last name Oishi doll
sounds like the japanese pronunciation
of the word acid cuz you know Hideko she
is gonna add puns wherever possible
lastly there is always a different
character featured on the spine of each
manga volume and you can find mina
resting comfortably on the spine of
volume 14 and that is it for today's
video guys I hope you learned something
new about Mina and your appreciation for
this underrated character has grown
definitely Texas smash that like button
if you enjoyed this video and want to
see more like it and use the quirk of
your choice to hit that subscribe button
and magic YouTube belt so you don't miss
any new MHA content remember to follow
us on Twitch to see us play my hero
academia wants justice when it comes out
I'm actually extremely excited for that
anyways thank you so much for watching
and until next time
see you space cowboys
[Music]
you